show them the
live on like he would big smiles
big heart big service all love
officer sean collier we
the institute convened a committee to
think about a memorial for sean
collier the
figure of the memorial as a kind of
five-walled structure is extruded
and then a void is actually carved out
of it
and that void represents a kind of
absence or a loss
the form itself is based on the hand
representing both a kind of gesture
of openness to others but also the
ability
to apply oneself to make things better
we wanted the stone to be representative
of the places where sean spent a lot of
time with like the mit community he was
very active with the mit outing club
so you know we started thinking about
you know granite new hampshire
the memorial is made of 32
blocks which piece together in a way
that allows each block to hold the other
one
up i'll go around and get the other
two so its strength comes from unity its
strength comes from the many
as opposed to a kind of singular gesture
so here
it's 90 and a half and here it's 91 and
a half
people don't build anymore this way so
it's an experiment in using really sort
of old-fashioned
techniques of stone masonry sort of
pre-modern almost if you will
but using high-end computers to sort of
determine
the shape and the layout of the stones
i'm saying 116.
so we're saying this is a1
it's great it fits perfectly
five walls actually extend out from the
center void
and as they extend out they frame
very specific views the two walls that
are closest together
align with the location of sean's
cruiser where he was shot
it's the most intimate space in the
memorial
when you're under it frames exactly
that spot where the tragedy occurred
what we really have are five half arches
which are each leaning in toward the
middle
and while that half arch should fall
over there's another half arch somewhere
else leaning in
and another half arch and another half
arch so each of these are coming
together
and balancing perfectly in the middle so
the arch is exerting an outward force
in the walls the five radiating walls
are buttressing
the central part of a very flat vault
as those arches push outward on the
walls the walls want to spread apart
and so buried underground there's a
tension tie
which is pulling back toward the center
and which is pulling the whole
memorial together so it's an equilibrium
below ground there's a great beam which
is poured in concrete
and it's reinforced concrete so there's
steel embedded within the concrete which
carries the tensile forces
to ensure that the walls will not move
outward
over the centuries the structural
engineering firm nippers helbig advanced
engineering developed extensive
computational models to test the
structure's performance
earthquake forces geotechnical
conditions and weathering
were all concerns that drove the final
engineering and detailing of the
memorial
the outside of this sculpture is all
going to be a flame
finish this is a very fine green very
dense granite and
leaves still a fairly flat but a more
natural textured surface
each stone is cut with advanced milling
technology some of the stones are cut by
robots
and the accuracy of each stone is within
about one millimeter
even as the robot is carving the blocks
someone has to come in and tap every
single
piece and break it off kind of one by
one
before then the robot can come in for
its final pass
it was a kind of incredible dance
between like machine
and man to carve these pieces
it's like a three-dimensional jigsaw
puzzle
with finely polished blocks of granite
but in this case they weigh about 10 000
pounds each
my name's rob rogers i'm a project
manager with suffolk construction
i'm also sean collier's brother
there's a sequence on how we're going to
lower the stones
so in theory the stone should
lock in place ready for the leverage
when the first blocks arrive and start
to take
physical form as an architect that's a
magical moment
when a concept turns into
physical reality
there were many times in this whole
project where we had to
keep our emotions in check because
it was such an emotional project for for
everyone involved
it's been a very humbling and
healing you know in in the past
almost two years since sean was gone so
it's really helped a lot
we started with the keystone and we had
to build a temporary scaffold under that
keystone
then the ring stones that surround the
keystone
came in next and we sequentially went
through each of the five legs
this has probably been the hardest
season to build in
we have 109 inches worst winter ever in
boston
it made things more challenging but
everyone on site was great i mean we
kind of knew
hey we have an end date we need to meet
this date so guys
worked harder they worked longer
the most exciting moment and the most
critical moment in the construction
is when we lower the scaffolding and the
weight of the great keystone
and the flat vault goes into the five
walls
really for the first time
we've got it instrumented for
displacements in 25 different locations
and then we've got nine scales
underneath it taking load readings
so we're going to be doing real-time
measurements of how the load is being
transferred
so we're going to go ahead and start
with the four middle ones one two
three now half inch as we lower the
temporary supports and they come
down the load on the scale should come
down
and the load on the scales will be going
down because the weight of the stones
will be going into arching
if we lower the supports and the reading
on the scale doesn't change
that's bad one two
wow yeah baby great
so behind b leg is a little part of my
speech that i gave
for sean so they engraved it
onto the stone so live long like he
would big hearts big smiles
big service all love
he was just a kid that just loved being
a cop you know he had
a million friends i don't know how he
slept he was always
doing something hanging out with
somebody you know
he really lived life to its you know
fullest
he was made to be a police officer and i
know his mother said he wanted to be a
policeman from the time he was seven
years old
and it showed it showed in everything he
did he got it
it's a very open structure for something
built out of such solid stone and it's
sort of supposed to be
a gateway into campus you know there's
people milling around they spend a lot
of time in north court they like to be
outside
and so you know we have these benches
and i think there will be trees
and it will hopefully become a place
that people really enjoy
sitting down and spending some time with
their friends and with the community
i hope the memorial will become one of
the
beloved elements on campus hopefully it
can
remain for us to remember sean's service
and the coming together of the community
and our values
i know things are gonna be much better
if we only will